(house band plays)
- Welcome back y'all.
Our next guest knows what
it's like to be surrounded
by the extraordinary.
Her dad, Clarence, known
as the Black Godfather,
was the chairman of Motown
Records, no big deal.
Her mom, Jacqueline,
which, I love that name,
was a huge activist and philanthropist
in South Central Los Angeles.
And, she's a powerhouse
in her own right, as well.
Her new book is called
"Think You'll Be Happy,
Moving Through Grief With
Grit, Gratitude, and Grace."
Great title, great subject matter.
Let's, everybody, welcome
back Nicole Avant. Come on!
(audience cheers)
So welcome, welcome back to the show.
- Thank you.
- Yes.
So, I have to ask, writing
a book is such a huge thing.
Like, I don't know if I'd
ever do something like that.
It's so hard, and it's,
you've gotta be so vulnerable,
and a lot has happened in your life.
- Yes.
- Like, even since this is,
you started the book,
and then throughout it.
So, how do you deal, like,
the loss of your dad,
like, and going through
this book, and being honest.
- You know, the writing helps,
as I'm sure a lot of
you guys know, writing,
and I'm sure you too.
- Oh man.
- When you write it out for a song,
it gets all of your emotions out.
It helps you own what you're feeling.
- And, I think.
- It's almost like you
recognize what you are feeling.
- You recognize what you're
feeling by writing it out.
That's why journaling works. You know?
And, so yes, it was hard writing the book,
but it was hard in a good way.
It was challenging.
And, I had already been
writing a book, you know,
before anything happened
with my mom and my dad.
And, I had written it after
"The Black Godfather."
I thought the themes,
grit, gratitude, and grace,
- Yeah.
Came out of the documentary,
"The Black Godfather."
- Yeah.
- And, that's what I was gonna write.
And, then we actually
did, I was on the show.
- Came on the show, I know.
- And, you ended, and you
know, when you end a Zoom
and it says, "Leave now,"
we didn't actually leave.
And, you said she should write a book.
And, I was, just,
I had just started "Grit,
Gratitude, and Grace."
And, you were the one
who gave me the fuel.
I kept saying, "I don't
know how to write this.
I don't know what I'm doing,"
and you did that for me.
(audience cheers)
So, you're a part.
- 'Cause when you listen
to you speak about it,
you're such a great speaker
and you're so vulnerable.
Not everybody's able to go to that place.
- Yeah.
- Like, that's a very hard place to go to.
But, what I find interesting is,
so you were already writing,
You lose your mama, you lost your daddy.
There's so much that happened,
and they weren't that far apart.
- No.
- Like, so much to happen
while you're writing this.
So, it definitely had to alter the book.
- It altered the book completely.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I, so, like I said, I was
starting on "Grits, Grace
and Gratitude," and then my
mom unfortunately was killed.
And it was so shocking and traumatic,
as anything would be like that.
And, I naturally, my human instinct was,
"Okay, I'm just gonna
leave this for a while.
People will understand why
I'm not continuing to write."
- Yeah.
- I go,
"How am I gonna put a book out
on "Grits, Grace, and Gratitude,"
and my mom just died?"
- Yeah.
- And then, somebody on my
team said, "But, wait a minute.
You know, let's think about it.
Jackie could be throughout this book.
And, her last text to me
was, "Think you'll be happy."
Those are the last
words my mom said to me,
"Think you'll be happy."
And, we just moved it
all together, and went,
"Wait a minute, that's
the title of the book,
because it is the mantra that she gave me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To live my life.
- It's amazing to me to think
about everything changed.
And, I'm a person that
thinks everything happens
for a reason, even if it's horrible.
- Me too.
- And, it's one of
those things, it's like,
how in incredibly magical
that they still live on
through this book that you were writing,
that was supposedly about something else,
and now it becomes
something bigger than that.
And, so much more helpful, by the way,
to all the people that are
going through such grief
and loss.
- I agree.
- Yeah.
- And, 'cause grief comes
in different waves, as we all know.
- Oh, I think divorce is grief.
That's a death.
- It's grief. It's a death.
- Yeah.
- And relationships die.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, dogs die.
- And, parents die, and
children, or no one has to die.
Grief is, you could lose a
job that you love so much.
- Yeah.
- And all of a sudden you're
fired. You lose something.
But, like I say in the
book, it is the receipt,
grief is the receipt that you loved,
that you loved something.
'Cause if you didn't, you wouldn't.
- This is why I told her to write a book!
(all laugh)
(audience cheers)
It's a bumper sticker. I'm like, what?
I would wear that on
a shirt as a reminder.
- It is a receipt that you've loved,
and you've been loved, hopefully.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, that's really what
this journey of life is.
All of us are gonna feel grief.
All of us are gonna feel sadness.
- To know that it's inevitable.
- It's inevitable.
Trials and tribulations come to everybody.
- Yeah.
- And so, I was hoping
that this book, kind of,
yes, it's about moving
through grief, of course,
but it also is about living,
this book is about life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This book is about survival,
and legacy, and love,
and compassion, and
serving others, you know,
and I just used my Mom.
- Which makes me feel
so great serving others.
- Yeah, so I use, I was able
to take the pain that I felt
for what happened to my mom.
And, I thought, "Well the
best way I can honor her
is to live a full life, and
do things that made her happy
so that it continues her legacy."
- And, then make you happy.
- And talk about her.
- Yeah.
And, I never wanted anyone
to forget Jacqueline Avant.
And, I thought, "You know what?
If there's all this news about my mom,
and it's so sensational, then
I'm gonna write her story."
- Yeah.
- "I'm gonna talk about Jacqueline Avant.
- But, who would know it best?
- Right.
- Yeah.
- You know, so.
- It's a beautiful book,
and it's.
- Thank you.
- It's gonna be helpful to so many,
it's a lot of hardship
you had to go through,
but it's a beautiful thing
to be able to use that,
your testimony.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yes.
- Nicole's book,
"Think You'll Be Happy," is out now.
Y'all gotta get yourself a copy.